pour de semaine tout compris ça coûte je
crois 370 francs à tous les prix sont le
voyage logés et nourris
et de plongée par jeu rendre accessible
ce sport en plein air à tous les jeunes
voici le but de l'association ucpa
lorsqu'elle est fondée en 1965 sous
l'impulsion de charles de gaulle alors
président de la république
la volonté du gouvernement est alors
clair que chaque jeune puisse partir en
vacances quel que soit son milieu social
j'ai tout qui va te quel âge d alors
est-ce que j'étais déjà venu première
fois vous aviez déjà pris les vacances
n'ont jamais une seule condition à
l'époque pour en bénéficier
avoir entre 16 et 30 ans pour les plus
démunis des bourses sont même offerte
par le ministère de la jeunesse et des
sports
c'est le ministère de la jeunesse et des
sports qui dans son souci de faire
connaître les sports de plein air à la
jeunesse a décidé de l'offrir le départ
à de nombreux jeunes ils pourront
pratiquer l'alpinisme la voile le canoë
kayak
aujourd'hui l'ucp arrive presque à
s'autofinancer par rapport aux autres
associations de son genre les
subventions de l'état représentent ainsi
moins de 1 % de son budget mais la
mission du gouvernement reste la même
qu'il ya 50 ans bon message principal
c'est celui là c'est tous les enfants
doivent partir en vacances si tu laisses
est une évidence et en france tout un
monde de d'associations et d'organismes
qui font beaucoup pour cela aujourd'hui
l'ucp a bien évolué et ne s'adresse plus
seulement aux jeunes des stages sont
proposés de 4 à 55 ans chaque année près
de 3 4 millions de personnes partent
avec l'association
[Musique]